in order to have a respectable
understanding of the Vietnam War we have
to rewind all the way back to the late
1800s when France was colonizing
Southeast Asia and in particular it
colonized what it's now Laos Vietnam and
Cambodia that were collectively called
French Indochina you can see Cambodia
here Vietnam along the coast and then
Laos right over here and France stayed
the colonizing power have a little gap
in my timeline here and they stayed a
colonizing power all the way through all
the way through World War all the way
through World War two and so you can
imagine during World War 2 France was
quickly overrun by the Germans the
Vietnamese wanted their independence and
so you have a liberation movement that
rises up and it was led by the Viet Minh
and the Viet Minh were led by Ho Chi
Minh this right here is a picture this
right here is a picture of Ho Chi Minh
and besides being a liberation movement
they were also communist they were also
communist which you could imagine later
on during the Cold War we'll kind of
bias the United States against them but
you fast-forward through World War two
eventually the Japanese take control
over Indochina over Vietnam and but by
the time 45 rolls about or at least the
end of 45 and we know that the United
States defeats Japan now all of a sudden
the Viet Minh are able to declare a
somewhat temporary independence and it's
temporary because shortly after that and
the region is occupied temporarily by
the Chinese in the north and and the
British in the south who were part of
the Allied forces against the axis but
eventually you have the French coming
back and they want to reassert their
their control over their former colony
and you have this war that develops the
first Indochina war between the French
and the people sympathetic to the French
the the Vietnamese were loyal to the
French and the north and the French and
just to make it clear how it sets up
when when at the end of World War two
when you had the temporary occupiers the
British and the Chinese the Chinese
obviously had more influence in the
north the British had more influence in
the south when the French come back they
essentially are able to reinstate
control
over the south so right when this the
the Indochina war is beginning the
French already have more control over
the south and actually historically the
French had more influence in the south
as well during French colonial rule is
really the southern third of Vietnam
where you had a lot of French influence
and this is a current map and the
current map does not have this orange
boundary over here that we'll talk about
in a second it's all Vietnam is now
unified but before the Vietnam War this
was not Ho Chi Minh City this was this
was Saigon and Saigon was kind of where
most of the French control was centered
but here fast-forward to 1954 this ends
up in a bit of a stalemate and so you
have the Geneva Conference of 1954 that
partitions Vietnam along the 17th
parallel between North and Vietnam and
South Vietnam and the whole point of
this partition was really to just allow
for a cooling-off period a period where
you could have things settling down and
then having elections it wasn't meant to
be a permanent partition but there was a
300-day period where people could move
across the partition and during that
partition you actually had 900,000
people mainly Catholics move from the
north to south you also had several
hundred thousand people moving from the
south to the north so it wasn't a
one-way movement but net-net
most of the movements by Roman Catholic
Vietnamese was from the north to the
south you fast-forward a little bit you
eventually have and and I'm sure I'm
butchering the pronunciation here no
Dinh Diem
take control he starts off as Prime
Minister in 54 eventually he takes
control becomes president in 55 this is
him right here he takes control of South
Vietnam and this guy is not a big fan of
things like elections or or non corrupt
government and and all of the rest and
he takes control of South Vietnam but
you can imagine that the United States
is positively inclined to him one he you
know he dresses in Nice western suits
and all of that nicely combed hair but
he was also anti-communist and at this
time period the United States is
starting to think in terms of Cold War
in terms of how do we stop communism how
do we contain it this whole theory of
containment that the best way to stop
the Soviet Union is to just make sure
that communism can
not spread that it gets contained that
we have the domino theory in the United
States that if one country Falls to
communism in a region that the rest of
the countries will eventually fall and
that is not good for containment so we
did not want South Vietnam to fall we
essentially start supporting these
characters over here and even from the
early 50s the United States starts
supporting the anti-communist and at
first this support it's in the I guess
we should say the guise of advisors but
these advisors one we start sending more
and more aid more and more advisors and
these advisors start getting more and
more involved in the actual conflict and
so after this partition you can imagine
that you still have an ongoing conflict
between the north and the south and on
top of that you have actors who are
sympathetic to the north sympathetic to
the Viet Minh sympathetic to Ho Chi Minh
in the south some of them were in the
north they come back to the south some
of them were just in the south and they
did not like the diem government of it
besides just being sympathetic the Ho
Chi Minh diem was a fairly corrupt
AutoTrack rata cruller who wasn't a big
fan of democracy and so these these
players in the south who started to rise
up against against President diem or the
Vietcong the Vietcong and so this is
really sets up what the Vietnam War is
all about you have the Communist Ho Chi
Minh controlled North that was fighting
a conventional war against the south you
have this you have this partition on the
17th parallel and on top of that you
have an unconventional fighting force I
guess you'd call guerrillas in the in
the south of Vietnam called the Vietcong
so it was kind of a double there are two
things that the South had to fight
against the North officially and also
this this insurrection that was
occurring within the south and so the
whole time the United States did not
want this insurrection to succeed they
did not want all of Vietnam to become
communist we keep sending more and more
advisors it actually started even before
Kennedy but in Kennedy he starts sending
the escalates the number of advisors
that get sent it's still not at this
point it's still not a formal war we
haven't officially declared where we
don't have officially soldiers in
battle-ax fast-forward to 1963 besides
all of the great characteristics of diem
that I already mentioned he also was
into persecuting Buddhists so to make
matters worse so you know not only was
he corrupt not only did he not like
elections but he liked persecuting his
own people and by 69 by 1963 this kind
of got out of hand he his level of
persecution of the Buddhists he started
toward storming temples and all the rest
and so he was assassinated and not only
was he he's assassinated it kind of
leaves this power vacuum we have all of
these people jockeying for control none
of these really especially savory
characters inside the South these two
guys eventually come to power when cow
Chi and win van to wait a few years when
van too is able to get this guy out of
the picture and then by 1967 I don't
have it over here 1967 you have to is
has now taken control but during that
period or actually before Chi and to
take power in 1964 you have one of the
shadiest incidents in American history
as you can imagine we as in our function
as it advisors we had sent ships into
the Gulf of Tonkin right after off of
the coast of North Vietnam and so the
original story goes and this is a very
suspect original story in 1964 the u.s.
Maddox and this is the original story
claimed that it was attacked or it was
claimed that the u.s. Maddox was
attacked by North North Vietnamese
patrol boats and that there were some
you know there was a little bit of the
skirmish there was an exchange of fire
and it was also claimed that a few days
later another boat in the Gulf of Tonkin
another US vessel was attacked by a
North Vietnamese boat that was the
original story this angered Congress
this angered the American people you
know how dare they
attack ships that are sitting off of the
coast warships that are sitting off the
coast and so this kind of gave this kind
of gave the the emotional the emotional
fuel to pass the Gulf of Tonkin
Resolution so these incidents or these
purported incidents this kind of attack
on the USS Maddox and this other thing
that might have happened
were called the gulf of tonkin incidents
this angered Congress angered the
American people so we passed the Gulf of
Tonkin Resolution and what's relevant
about it is it gave LBJ here it gave him
the authority to officially engage in a
war in Vietnam to officially escalate it
to an actual war that the u.s. was
involved in and this whole time I've
been saying it's shady because it's now
been shown that won the Gulf of Tonkin
well it's not clear that really anything
happened there might have been some
firing from the USS Maddox it they might
did they might have actually engaged the
north the North Vietnamese patrol boats
the other possibility that might have
happened is that they that nothing
happened so but either way you any way
you look at it it's now been fairly
established that it was not a real
incident it was not really North Vietnam
attacking attacking the United States
but it was Val it was it was relevant
because it really escalated the war so
now you have Johnson did I say North
Korea originally I apologize for that
we're talking about North Vietnam I
don't remember what my brain actually
said of course North Vietnam but it gave
it gave Johnson the the the power to
escalate the war and so his
administration is really the heart of
the Vietnam War when the war was really
escalated we eventually get to 500,000
US troops but the whole time this is
happening you can imagine that Johnson
and the military leaders in Viet and the
American military leaders in Vietnam are
telling the American people oh we're
fighting communism we're about to win
this is a noble war and you fast forward
and you know especially the part about
to win you fast forward to 1968 and all
of a sudden you have the Vietcong who
the American leaders have told the
American people in the Congress that are
they're about to be defeated and then in
1968 the Vietcong orchestrate the Tet
Offensive which is this this massive
coordinated attack on a bunch of targets
throughout throughout throughout South
Vietnam and so even though it was wasn't
completely successful militarily the
intent of the Tet Offensive was to kind
of completely turn the tides in the war
it made the American people and Congress
rightfully suspicious you you know mr.
Johnson you had told us you had told us
that we were about to win the war and we
were about to you know the Vietcong
we're almost defeated and all of a
sudden they orchestrate this this
sophisticated attack on us it rightfully
made the American public suspicious on
top of that and you know this this
probably made matters a lot worse the My
Lai massacre comes out and in every war
there are massacres but the United
States at least believes that it's it's
it's soldiers can kind of take the high
road that it's it's they don't engage in
in these type of things but the My Lai
massacre show that really no soldiers
are immune to massacres and this is
really a disgusting massacre and it was
documented and if you really want to be
disturbed do a Google search for images
of the My Lai massacre it will ruin your
weekend
it'll depress you you know it's it's US
soldiers killing a village of innocent
women and children there's pictures of
dead babies it's horrible and on top of
to make matters worse or even you know
add insult to injury the soldiers who
committed it there was actually a few
who tried to defend the the villagers
and they were when they came back they
were they were created almost like
traitors but the soldiers who actually
did the attack only one of them got jail
time it was only a couple of years of
jail time and this is for massacring a
village of women and children so already
you had the Tet Offensive makes the
American public suspicious of whether we
can even win this war and then you have
the My Lai massacre which just discussed
the public and and and and makes people
realize that we're involved in a war
that not even clear who are the good
guys anymore not even clear what the
real goals are make matters worse you
fast forward to 1971 the Pentagon Papers
get leaked to the New York Times and
these pretty much articulate it's a
classified document that articulates
that the leadership the military and
non-military leadership of the Vietnam
War was to some degree lying to Congress
and the American people was lying about
how the war was going it was lying about
what activities it was doing it did not
tell the American people of Congress
that it was actually engaged in war in
Laos and Cambodia and a lot of the
reason why we were in gay
Laos and Cambodia is because that's
where the supply routes were between the
north and the south
they ran through Laos and Cambodia and
the most famous of them and you might
have heard of it is the Ho Chi Minh
Trail and it wasn't just one trail it
was actually a network of trail and so a
lot of the activity that was going on in
Laos and Cambodia was kind of carpet
bombing of what the the US thought were
some of these supply routes and we never
really got a good you know we never well
that's a whole other debate but the it
wasn't just one trail that was easily
bombed it was all of these little
footpaths and all of these other things
where arms were able to be transported
from the north to the south but the
Pentagon Papers rightfully made the
American people even more suspicious and
then now we're entering into Nixon's
administration and he was still doing
the carpet bombing you know still
atrocities going on but he his whole
goal was to kind of wind down the war
bring the troops out on a timetable
without kind of a an official defeat so
you fast-forward to 1973 you have the
Paris Peace Accords we're officially
there is peace between the the north the
South the north and the Americans you
can imagine it from the North's point of
view they're like sure we'll sign some
piece of chords it'll just make the
Americans go away once the Americans go
away they won't be able to come back
since this was such a hugely unpopular
war it was it was such a such a waste of
for America on so many dimensions
especially America's prestige is a
global actor we'll just wait for them to
leave and then we can overrun the south
after that and that's essentially what
happens in 1975 the North just overruns
the south and then in and then later
that year you have set you have Saigon
falling to the north and then it becomes
Ho Chi Minh City and just this whole
period you have President to is in power
and just to show where his priorities
are right near the end right when the
north is falling to South Vietnam and
you can kind of see the writing on the
wall he gives a speech to the Vietnamese
people saying that he'll never desert
them but then when he when he really
makes it when it becomes pretty clear
that that Saigon is going to fall to the
North Vietnamese he gets on a big on a
big US transport plane with literally 15
tons of luggage
fifteen tons of luggage I'll let you
think about how much luggage that is and
15 million dollars 15 million dollars
worth of gold and this is 15 million
dollars worth of gold in 1975 so you can
imagine how much he really cared about
about the Vietnamese people and he
eventually ends up settling in
Massachusetts and he died there in about
about ten years ago so you can imagine
this was a ugly incident for the world
an ugly super ugly incident for the
Vietnamese people a super ugly chapter
in American history it was the first war
that won America lost but more it hurts
prestige it hurts America's ability to
influence what was going on in other
parts of the world you know you had the
containment theory that you know we had
to stop communism from spreading and in
the domino theory that if if one country
would fail to come fall to communism
then the other one word that didn't
happen the south did fall but we didn't
have the rest of Southeast Asia falling
to communism so it kind of disproved the
the domino theory especially because
after the Vietnam War that the United
States would not be able to enter
another war like it for some time
because the American people wouldn't let
it happen so to some degree would've
been easier for communism to spread
because people would have known that the
u.s. couldn't engage it but despite that
the domino theory didn't happen but it
was just all-around ugly I mean just the
the besides the massacres and the raping
and the pillaging of innocents that
happened on really on all sides of this
you have one to three million Vietnamese
Vietnamese and no one will really know
the actual count but that's a huge
number 1 to 3 million Vietnamese were
killed
you have 58,000 58,000 American troops
being killed American troops and you
have hundreds of thousands of Cambodians
and lotions who are never really
formally involved in the war they were
they were killed especially due to a lot
of this carpet bombing campaign so these
are these are these are I mean just
atrocious numbers and and really one of
the worst and ugliest chapters in US
history